the adopted son that filmmaker Woody
Allen is defending his father against
accusations Allen sexually assaulted his
adopted daughter nearly three decades
ago in a lengthy blog post yesterday
Moses Farrow said he can no longer stay
silent as his father quote continues to
be condemned for a crime he did not
commit Moses his younger sister Dylan
Farrow claims Allen's sexually assaulted
her when she was seven Allen has always
denied that Yana golodryga shows us
Moses's new accusations against his
mother Fionna good morning good morning
some detailed accusations at that Moses
Farrow claims his adoptive mother Mia
Farrow raised her children by coaching
influencing and rehearsing he says his
father never assaulted his sister Dylan
Farrow and suggests the story was likely
planted in Dylan's head there's no moral
that's Moses Farrow in 1992 publicly
denouncing his father Woody Allen but in
a post on his blog Wednesday Moses
describes that moment as the biggest
regret of his life Moses claims he
endured years of mental and physical
abuse at the hands of his mother Mia
Farrow and that led to him being
obedient and deeply afraid of her I'm
told it happened here in the Attic
yeah in 1992 seven-year-old Dylan Farrow
claimed she was sexually assaulted by
Allen in the Attic of her mother's
Connecticut home an allegation she has
maintained for nearly 30 years
but Wednesday Moses said he was with
Dylan and his father the day of the
alleged assault and it never happened he
said no one would have allowed Dylan to
step away with Allen alone because his
mother made them believe he was a
monster Mia Farrow and Allen split a few
months before the alleged assault after
it came to light he was dating Mia
Farrow's 21 year old adopted daughter
soon-yi Mia called me on the phone and
said in the course of an argumentative
phone call she said I have something
very nasty planned for you in a 1992
interview with 60 minutes Allen denied
assaulting Dylan either she has been
coached methodically to to tell the
story because by Mia by Mia yeah I want
to speak out literally in an interview
with Gayle King in January Dylan denied
her adoptive mother's alleged scheme
what I don't understand is how is this
crazy story of me being brainwashed and
coached more believable than what I'm
saying about being sexually assaulted by
my father Mia Farrow has previously
denied being abusive
in a statement Dylan Farrow called her
brothers claims easily disproven and
contradicted by years of his own
statements Mia Farrow did not respond to
our request for comment Woody Allen
declined to comment he has not been
charged with a crime look this is really
heartbreaking and whatever happened that
day divided this family permanently and
you're hearing multiple sides here I
know you spend a lot of time with Dylan
as well and it's complicated beyond it
and I do talk to Dylan yesterday she
says listen she and her mother both are
devastated by Moses latest turn of
events because he's contradicting
himself again she says and she said I
haven't spoken to him since July 2009
neither one of us have spoken to him and
and because he's never talked to me
about it we've never discussed the
incident how can
say what he's saying so she has no
response to him directly she said I
don't want my me to moment to turn into
a very bad version of family feud
so she says I'm not going to respond to
him it is it's complicated in
heartbreaking on on all's there are no
winners but when you talk to Dylan
people talk to Dylan find her very
credible and very believable and read
the reports the reports say a lot in the
reports on this case Thank You bianna
thank you